hi my name is mentioned pen I'm with
warfarin research I McConnell developer
in visualization today I will talk about
core visualization thank you
so in the end of the talk we will see
that how did I make this plot which
consists of exclusions and thus well
this one doesn't have scaling functions
but there is a call out and Leah's plan
labels it doesn't have the labeling
function but because it is the wrong
plot to have that but that's my goal for
today ok so for exclusions eden has
talked about the the core computation
about how to find exclusions and the
discontinuities here I want to talk
about how's that what's the interface
that when it applies to the
visualization exclusions this option is
not a new options that we have added
this probably since version 6 I think
yes and but we did extend the option
values in pershing 11 thats the
discontinuity you see and singularities
thanks to adam these two free sets can
find a different types of continuity's
you know you don't need to worry about
it anymore most of the time and right so
this is kind of the famous plot which is
a tangent X the central line in the at
the poles are coming from the line
between positive infinity and negative
infinity previously we there I mean the
the algorithm couldn't find this pose
automatically so that we didn't remove
it you have to hand our manually specify
where the positions you want to remove
so but in the version 11 ok slide mode
slideshow mode doesn't have the auto
completion hope I can type
so in version 11 automatic exclusions
can remove of exclusions and what is
behind the thing is that when they come
well because of the exclusion code can
find where the exclusions add and behind
the scene when we we are looking we're
comparing that what's the sign of the
function around that points and with if
we find that if the science change then
we just simply don't generate the lines
at that point so that's what's happening
in the plot and to show that it's
actually we get removed you can specify
exclusion style then you can see then
these are the lines where the exclusions
had so they're different types of
discontinuity is this one is removable
discontinuity that it you don't really
see it because they are only at the
point I can show that to you if I
specify the exclusion style in a very
dramatic way then what yes the
exclusions are there and has been
removed for the jump discontinuity I did
define a kind of like cheating function
which is a piecewise function to create
this jump again the exclusion styles
after it is specified then you can see
where the the jump happens that's what
we're it's get removed like I said the
nice thing about the version 11
exclusion is that this is all done
automatically here I have a very
complicated piecewise function then it
consists of all sorts of different
discontinuities and then they can be
found automatically and those are the
presets that I talked about
so if if you want to know what kind of
discontinuity is that it happens you can
just change the different presets right
so this is the singularities we can also
find a branch card not exactly what Oleg
was talking about but for the 3d plots
this can be shown and for the density
plot in contour plot this can be also
detected automatically okay next scene
is scaling functions this function icing
has been there for couple versions
already but i think we started to more
make it more visible right version 8 for
the charting functions but we make it
more visible for the plots in the post
version 10 i believe and in version 11
we complete the list list and i want to
talk about that what happened in the
previous versions so in version 10.4 or
10.3 actually we study to adam scaling
functions to the list plot in this line
plot for some plots that both dimensions
make sense we will have scaling
functions on each dimension or each
direction for example this one I only
specified log on the X direction and
well let's place the same scene and
we're going to the daily splat which we
currently don't support the log date
mainly because of the anomaly of
negative values how we count the times
yes epic here i use the skinny function
reverse on the y-axis i think this is a
nice feature that other people have been
asking about
because of aiding scaling functions we
pretty much make all these lists lock
please log log plot this log linear plot
and Daily slog flood aliases yes we have
all of them and in version 11 we
extended the scaling function to the
plot which big log plot log log plot log
linear plot aliases and well this is a
small manipulation that you can see how
it work and our plan for the future is
where we have the scaling functions
coming to the Geographics plots and also
for the 3d plots so we kind of like
doing this progressively okay so how
what's been done behind the scene is
actually so for example I have a I have
a plot which but have paused at cosine X
equal to 0 so if I really want to use
the scaling function to transform this
into something different then it's it
it's there is nothing magical here so we
just define our scaling functions the
scaling function for example here will
be just the inverse or reverted scaling
function and we apply that skinny
function on and the function itself
first then pretty much the curve is what
we wanted but all these the details the
framework the tix and the grid lines and
the coordinate tools they are still in
the original domain so this is just a
demonstration
conceptually that how it did it so then
we because we need to convert back the
tickets into the original domain so we
have to use the inverse scaling
functions to find it so here is what you
look like after changing the tix it may
think quite simple here but believe me
it is a huge work to figure out what the
nice tix should be especially for the
freeform scaling functions another
mention is the coordinate tool options
so if i do the comment that or a
controlled oops how do i get the
coordinates oh here yes i will be public
can see it but here there should be like
a a pair of values of the graphics
because i haven't done any modification
here yet so they are the values in the
transform the domain ideally or which is
done internally they have been inversed
as well so you will gather these values
correct so these are just one other
options that we handled here but in the
internal functions we handle all the
gridlines the friend takes the epilogue
all the graphics options has been
handled
okay next thing I want to talk about is
rapers labeled and call out in ten point
four and before we have added I mean
nothing the label raper for the chatting
functions is ended when the chatham
functions were created that was in
version 7 but idea to use the label
rapper is just labeled with the data and
the label so here this bar chart and
here is the label that I use one two
three four so that's simple in the
version 10.4 we decided to extend the
label rappers to the scatter plots which
is this plot this is a very difficult
problem especially when the data says
has some characteristics for example
like this one a kind of distribute along
the diagonal lines then this is only
like 15 points if you have like 30
points all distributed in the diagonal
lines they are going to they doom to
collide and how do you find the labels
that's not colliding that is a not so
easy job so I I'm not saying that we
have solved the problem one hundred
percent because well it depends on how
many positions you can have the label at
the point this can be an np-hard problem
so but we we have tried and this is the
results we have layer layer in version
10.4 this is another examples under this
line plot we tagged the you know the
lines between the points into the
considerations so the labels can avoid
the collision with the lines as well in
the version 11 we added
the support of labeled to the curves so
we want you to make it really simple so
you don't need to worry about you know
the collision so the syntax is just like
labeled for example this is a sign / x
and the label the end position and this
position I really mean just one value
for example like for what happens is
that it takes that values in and compute
what the Y values should be of that
label and then it will put the labels
well let's take into a lot of
considerations for example the lens of
the label and the image size of the
graphics and also the label style you
know if you have a huge long label then
it will take that into consideration as
well then we then we have a solution
here that as long as you just specify a
position it will find a spot that will
avoid the collision in the version 11 we
also added another thing called call out
there are still a lot of chances that
I'm especially in a more complicated or
more curves graphics if you just specify
a position like um you're using labeled
they can be ambiguous so we decided to
use the call out which has a leader line
to show where the label actually refer
to same thing we supported to the data
points as you can see this is not one
hundred percent ideal yet but we're
working on that right so someone has x
before that how do you specify the color
labels arbitrary or what's the interface
of it so here I want to introduce to
that
so they are couple scenes to know about
color label there is the leader which is
this the slope line here and there is
something called neck that connects to
the label when you space by the position
you actually specify the position of
this point right and just like labeled
when you specify sale opposition is at X
equal to 2 then it will trying to find
the position according to the function
so that the coil level is not going to
collide with them with the curve say
again I didn't catch that oh if I want
the label to be vertical yes there are
the options to to set that I will talk
about that okay so for example here I
only say that I want I wanted the
callout label at point two point five so
what's been decided automatically is
where the y position is of the label and
also where the leader point2 so if you
really really want the fine control like
for example if there is a certain
feature of the curve that you want to
point to then you have to specify where
the leader point to that would be next
example here I want to show you that it
actually did put some effort to find
where other free spaces are so that it
doesn't collide so here is a
manipulation that I can show you if I
say that I firebombed my label position
it's actually were computed the y
position according to where the leader
is specified here if it is not automatic
so that's why
it's it remains at the same y position
but if you change the leader where
points to then the Y position will also
change and there are a whole set of
options for call out which if I can type
options cloud right thanks to tim our
graphics designer that we have set off
appearance this probably doesn't show
much because it's too or there you go so
this is the default and there is a curve
the leader and well i'm going to show
just one like balloon or slanted right
so right so but you can also specify
where the position of label to be
exactly ad so for example i want to see
to be at this point then this is where
you specify the label is well if you
also specify with the label that mean
the leader points too I mean you can do
that but it doesn't I mean there is a
much difference from using just text if
you do this but ok for the data points
the code there is an option called the
leader size that you can specify the
lens of the leader and the length of the
neck probably won't see that but if I
something like that and you can do the
neck rotation
or the rotation of the whole leader I'm
going to make it automatic right so here
is all the detail controls you can have
okay the plot labels okay I don't have
much time here but like bread introduced
plant labels is there in version 10.4
what's good about it which has in its
Creed pretty clever is that when there
are lines that's very close to each
other the labels will not collide again
here the collision is our enemy so we
try to avoid that and this is what we
have done and all you need to do is just
too I mean potentially you can say apply
labels go to automatic but in this case
they are the solution of this dissolve
they are awfully long so I put something
else you can also say that I want the
flood levels not just on the right-hand
side but along the curve so here is your
syntax let you sleep laced and the
position something like that you can
also use call out if you want SoCo I
work just like to place the syntax you
can position them using the color
feature with all the details of the
options you we provided the lesson is
the labeling function this scene is only
implemented currently in the data
visualizations the charts and the list
plot is line plot and also have done
will also have to have done that in the
least step flood and daily staple at
these are the syntax but I really want
you to know that you know we have done a
lot of automations here for example if
your data I self-contained
some keys in the association then not
you don't need to specify any options
even labeling function itself it will
just automatically pick it up and using
the automatic leveling position it will
avoid the collisions one not so just to
show you that if you have the confidence
that if you place the label or on top of
the points nothing were collides then
you can do that as well otherwise
automatic will do that we put a little
effort to make sure that oops that if
you put the labels at center it can
replace the point sometimes they are
interesting and we are useful but for
example like that we also done that for
this step lot again this is more detail
control I can use the call-out to do the
work this is too just to show you the
arguments the first argument is the
value of the point the second argument
is the index of the point the third
argument is actually a collection of
various label mechanics that we provide
so here I kind of sneakily just choose
the last one which is the keys for data
and here is a real example okay
okay we're is all right the title of
this slide is called future works I
don't know where it went but but we are
occurring working on the cloud and
labeled features in the bubble chart
which is another challenge because now
we have to worry about the collisions
with regions and also if you like the
labeling functions in the timeline we
also extend that to the bar chart that's
something for the future and for the
stacked bar chart a lot of people have
trouble you know to place labels when
when the when the bar is very small so
we also have similar solutions to like
the plot labels for that so that will be
that concludes my talk thank you very
much
[Applause]